benjamin blanchard directeur général de
sos chrétiens d'orient bonsoir d'engins
blanchard merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france votre association vient en aide à
la syrie régulièrement que pensez vous
de cette impasse finalement sur
l'acheminement de lettres
transfrontalière dont soit magali
forestier alors bien sûr hélas hélas
puisque c'est la population syrienne qui
souffrent pendant ce conflit et qui va
payer le prix fort de ce blocage mais je
crois que la question posée par la
russie et la chine au conseil de
sécurité est très importante puisque
pourquoi vouloir à tout prix que l'aide
humanitaire des nations unies arrivent
uniquement par la province d'idlib qui
rappelons le est aux mains de groupes
armés qui souvent sont classés comme
terroristes avec notamment la branche
syrienne d'al-qaïda alors qu'il ya des
manières d'entrer dans le pays soit par
le port de lattaquié soit par là les
postes frontière avec la jordanie ou
avec le liban il n'y a eu je ne
comprends pas pourquoi il faudrait
absolument que l'aide humanitaire
un transit par la turquie et par les
zones tenues par les groupes armés
parfois terroristes sachant que la
l'immense majorité de la population
syrienne vidant désormais dans des zones
tenues par le gouvernement syrien donc
par le gouvernement syrien qui est
membre des nations unies
donc c'est assez incompréhensible je
trouve de vouloir passer à tout prix par
les zones dites l'ipd lui par des
groupes armés alors qu'ils les points de
passage dans des zones de conflits
effectivement on dit aussi acheminement
un d'armes en secret est ce que c'est ce
que craignent
la chine et la russie notamment qui ont
mis leur veto que des armes soient
acheminés vers ces organisations
terroristes c'est peut-être peut-être
également il ya un problème de
souveraineté de l'état syrien qui
rappelons le
je viens de le dire et membre des
nations unies pourquoi l'aide
humanitaire des nations unies ne rentre
pas par les points de passage contrôlé
par le gouvernement syrien et puis je
trouve qu'il ya une grande hypocrisie on
est en train d'affamer le peuple syrien
à travers d'une part des sanctions qui
ne sont pas nouvelles qui dure depuis
des années qui ont été renouvelés il ya
quelques semaines par l'union européenne
hélas et qui touchent vraiment de plein
fouet l'ensemble de la population et ces
sanctions étaient encore renforcée du
côté américain par les fameuses
sanctions césar et c'est un vraiment un
désastre économique un désastre
humanitaire alors c'est bien beau de
vouloir apporter de l'aide humanitaire
c'est tout à fait nécessaire c'est
indispensable mais ça n'a pas grand sens
si d'un autre côté on empêche les
syriens de vivre de se nourrir et de
l'économie de fonctionner au moins à
minima parce que comme d'habitude les
sanctions économiques gracieux que tout
le monde se rassure ne touche pas l'île
président syrien ni les rares que du
gouvernement mais bien sûr touche les
plus pauvres les plus fragiles et
l'ensemble de la population
effectivement ces sanctions césar qui
ont de lourdes répercussions sur sur la
population syrienne vous l'avez dit
qu'elles sont sassi de l'aide
humanitaire arrive dans le même temps
ces sanctions américaines concrètement
où est ce que vous l'avez vous constatez
sur le terrain quelle conséquence l oms
sur la population
alors les conséquences sont vraiment
très importante c'est difficile de
savoir quel est l'effet amplificateur
des sanctions césar parce qu'en fait la
crise économique c'est les gens plis
fier depuis le mois de septembre en fait
depuis le début de la q2 puis te liban
est tombé dans à son tour dans une grave
crise et également les sanctions
américaines contre certaines personnes
au liban ne sont peut-être pas pour rien
dans l'explosion de la crise bancaire
économico au liban mais disons que la
crise au liban influent beaucoup et
négativement sur la syrie puisque c'est
un des c'était le principal point
d'entrée
pour les marchandises étaient un peu la
bouffée d'air frais pour la syrie le
liban et donc depuis cette crise qui
s'éternise au liban depuis septembre
c'est vrai que l'économie syrienne va de
mal en pis et la monnaie syrienne la
livre syrienne a beaucoup chuté depuis
septembre et ça ça s'est encore
accélérée avec les sanctions césar
effectivement et donc on a on commence à
avoir des gens qui ont qui ont du mal à
se nourrir bien sûr est ce que vous
constatez aussi sur le terrain des
population syrienne qui continuent de
rentrer après s'être exilé en jordanie
ou en turquie n'ont actuellement tout
est bloqué à même les expatriés pour
l'instant ne peuvent pas rentrer en
syrie la syrie a été assez épargné par
le cornet virus et le gouvernement
visiblement cherche à maintenir le
blocus le plus longtemps possible pour
éviter justement que le pays soit touché
via des arrivées notamment deux
ressortissantes ils sont à l'extérieur
donc pour l'instant les frontières sont
assez hermétiquement fermées donc il ne
peut pas y avoir deux de retour que ce
soit pour les vacances pour les congés
ou pour se réinstaller
wauquiez acheminer de l'aide humanitaire
vers la sérié comment est ce que vous
allez pouvoir continuer à travailler ce
que vous espérez que cette situation de
blocage se dénouent oui bien sûr alors
nous nous achetons nous sommes unis nous
sommes pas les nations unies donc c'est
pas du tout les mêmes montants et les
mêmes quantités mais ce que nous faisons
nous le trouvons en syrie pour l'instant
heureusement trouve encore la plupart
des choses en syrie concernant que la
syrie vit quand même beaucoup en
autarcie donc c'est aussi pour ça que
les sanctions si elles font du mal nonna
six iep a complètement la syrie puisque
la syrie a su développer une économie où
l économie autarcique
donc on arrive à trouver la plupart des
choses en syrie par contre les prix
augmentent dangereusement et puis le
taux de change devient très très
difficile donc ça c'est ça c'est un vrai
problème pour nous et puis on a
également des gros problèmes pour faire
pour acheminer les fonds puisque c'est
c'est aujourd'hui très compliqué et la
syrie donc qui tentent de se rebâtir
aussi
politiquement la vie a repris néanmoins
dans ce pays
alors la vie ne s'est jamais vraiment
arrêté surtout dans les grandes villes
même au pire moment de la guerre même à
alep j'allais très souvent à l'ept quant
à l'epp été coupée en deux et même au
pire moment les restaurants rester
ouverts les gens continuer à aller fumer
et et boire des cafés d'été dans les
dents les dans les salons le parc de
park était toujours ouvert et donc la
vie a toujours continué mais évidemment
avec la fin de la diminution de
l'intensité des combats et le fait que
dans les trois quarts du pays désormais
soit pacifié on avait vu vraiment la vie
reprendre complètement les restaurants
pleins et c'est avec une joie de vivre
qui était très manifeste mais hélas
actuellement c'est de nouveau en train
de ralentir bien sûr il ya eu d'épidémie
de coronavirus avec un confinement très
très stricte
et puis là maintenant il ya vraiment des
problèmes économiques qui s'amplifie et
qui qui nous amène à une situation
vraiment vraiment dramatique et ça il
faut bien que les téléspectateurs s'en
rendent compte de la situation
humanitaire est très mauvaise en syrie
actuellement merci beaucoup d'engins
blanchard pour votre analyse
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
sur rt france